1378 kilometer australien mit singapore
airlines täglich im airbus a380 ab
zürich
[Musik]
sie lieben den schoppen und sie lieben
ihre milch australien estland vor der
freiwillige helfer die sogenannte
volunteers
genau darum
zürich die greentowers sie kümmert sich
ehrenamtlich um verwaiste kein gruß du
hast sie hat ihr geschäft gemacht
sie springt rein und schläft jetzt
können sie ein wenig trainieren und ihr
geschäft machen
auf diese seite ja darüber was ist eine
motivation für die freiwilligenarbeit
ich mache das weil ich eine große
leidenschaft für die tiere habe ich bin
überzeugt vom einsatz unserer
organisation
wir versuchen diese einzigartigen
einheimischen tiere zu schützen
in australien leben einige der
seltensten tiere der welt
die müssen wir schützen das kämpfen und
der eu sind uns erwarten tiere
es ist unheimlich toll wenn
nach der pflege wieder frei lassen und
sie zurück in die wildnis gehen verloren
[Musik]
freiwillige helfer die kernfragen
öffentlichen in australien
[Musik]
sie zwei wochen und forscht vier diese
kilometer bin jetzt unterwegs
bitte seid mir urs wälterlin der
korrespondent von schweizer radio und
fernsehen stadt kemberg auf dem
reißbrett gezeichnete stadt
das macht sie weniger kompliziert
[Musik]
der sicherheits national freaks denkmal
ich bin überrascht dass es das in
australien bleibt gibt der us
ausstrahlung gebrauch verschiedener zeit
als englische kolonie ist an sieben
verschiedenen mutterland in etliche
spieler und schlachter zeuge
ich lehre ein unbekannte bedrückende
sitter von glücklicher kontinent kennen
aber hoben die sich australien sind in
verschiedene reaktoren
[Musik]
das gedenken an gefallene und eine
fehlerfreie ware strahlender weg sind
also ich eigentlich
so will es das wichtigste machen das
land extrem wichtig also sich aber in
den letzten jahren immer wichtiger auch
der vor allem unter premierminister john
hartmann 690 welt worden ist
konservative daher dass wieder richtig
zelebriert
truls entdeckte prominente gäste waren
trotz vize-premierminister vor
australien monatelang aber ohne erfolg
probiert ein interview termin mit dem
minister zur branche begleitet
da oben ist er
wenn sie ist in frankreich beerdigt ich
bin sicher mein großonkel zog nicht das
heldentum den krieg geschweige denn weil
er unser land verteidigen musste er ging
weil es seine pflicht worden
aber in erster linie war das leben in
australien damals sehr hart war von
seiner fahren konnte er mehr schlecht
als recht leben verdiente als
minenarbeiter etwas dazu ich vermute ein
wichtiger anreiz in den krieg zu ziehen
waren die regelmäßigen mahlzeiten in der
armee und die möglichkeit europa zu
sehen
das hätte er sich sonst nie leisten
können zum abschied mahnte warnkross
nachdenklich vielleicht zehn australier
aus dankbarkeit in dankbarkeit dem
eigenen land gegenüber dem lakic
verschont blieb
ich frage mich wie viel kostet etwas
glück mit sicherheit viel für all die
kriegsopfer
[Musik]
nach dem ausflug lehrerfamilie von urs
wälterlin keine christine schmid frau
und der sohn david eine person samuel
wohnt sieht kurzem hier in der
hauptstadt wien reg en familie an der
öffentlichen schule macht die
internationale matur mutter christine
hatte schon länger mit maxi sich gerade
in europa gewarnt
das sehr genau wie lang ist's her
letzten mal gesehen den sohnemann zwei
wochen eine lange zeit auto stunde war
also verwandten in der schweiz oder in
deutschland weiter schwächen und restore
und darum sind wir doch sehr sehr wohl
aber relativ isoliert
aber wenn es nur eine stunde jetzt
nacheinander schule wird
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt wird familie walter
klappt erfahren
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt große fußball show
entschieden die jungen von meinem büro
oft räumt betrieb der journalistin
geriet das ist krieg mit hund moritz
produktion der us und christine henrich
vor über 20 jahren australier kenne und
liebe klärt mit den damen sind in
australien 6 und schied zu gefallen der
vag luft
es ist liebe auf der er spricht sie das
grundstück das der karabag gar nicht
das zieht sich verändert hinter uns in
einem grundstück insgesamt sind sie
ungefähr 30 hektar enthält aber das
grundstück bezichtigt dass das höchster
sofort wunde und es kann alles selber
baut oder überhaupt kein menschlicher
von menschen grundstücken angefangen wie
viele strahlen das machen sie erst
einmal kleine wohnwagen abgestellt und
zwar über das gesetz ist dann haben wir
große morgen angestellt wird familie
gewachsen ist und wenn ist im wohnwagen
als sie jedoch auch sehr kalter winter
in der regel meist nicht am start steht
immer heiß ganz so gar nicht an sich
halten und deshalb wird der strom kann
nur sagen wir sind jetzt hier
oder ist das für dich nach wie vor einen
temporären die wurzeln sind in der
schweiz ich beschließe ich bin schweizer
strahlen
ich erkläre den verlauf und sagen du
bist wo die menschen sind wo du lebst
wunsch jetzt in der schweiz 18
in der nachbarschaft herum gesprochen
dass der usc vom schweizer fernsehen
also der roten ist da und erwartet eine
ganze normale nachbarschaft party und
das findet im chat in gartenstadt
typisch australisch hallo mich schön
dich kennenzulernen
bei diesem heißen australischen wetter
habe ich immer so einen durst sehr gut
das gefällt mir
vielen dank
und nochmals danke für die einladung
und was ein typisches was ich jetzt
sehen was zeichnet den typischen
typischen steht ist das alles
dominierende von männersache der
großstadt ist es also dass das hirn er
ist wirklich meine da und porträts oder
pvp ist sie das besondere partie ist
frauen und männer einig verstrickten sie
sind man muss sie nur einen action und
handlung war es in den regeln fixie und
haben dort ihre sache des fuji bitte
davon freuen sie dürfen sogar mit
fremden flirte ich bin chili hallo ich
bin's wenn wie hast du's wenn wirklich
danke er ist in das eigentlich rede ich
nicht mit leuten deren namen ich nicht
kenne
normalerweise nimmt formen an gefallen
collectors dass ich noch nicht und das
land wäre der länge und der lustig aber
irgendwann beschließt den kolleg
vermutet walter lindl brian cox mit zu
den beats bringen das war ja nie schaden
lektion ist der knopf von unten hoch
durchs auge
oben drüber und drunter oben durch
wieder runter jetzt sieht es aus wie
eine nacht ist also der zahn profi hier
in der gutsscheune seit 60 jahren zum
gaudi von der ganzen nachbarschaft jetzt
screen hohen wie die schweiz und dann
durch und zu
die woche drauf da unten und oben
wieder unten durch und zurück hier
drücken noch ein wenig runter hier muss
ich jetzt auch draußen lehrbuch
[Musik]
liga nord hochburg voller in den strich
fid verlag.de billige synthetische
stoffe
[Musik]
hallo hallo schön dich kennenzulernen
wo ist die arbeit da sind einige
schaffen und dort der stein ist ein
schaf schäden ja aber ich würde mir
nicht versuchen
jahrhundert auch der doch sind zusammen
mit der erste siedlerverein land merino
schafe vor strahlung gibt sind rund acht
millionen tiere
der stall ist etwa 100 jahre das ist
aber wirklich alt geschaffen hast du
etwa 2000 zur zeit
das ist schön dich kennenzulernen
ich bin's wenn also er ist der kurve
also wie viele schafe schätzt du in
einem jahr pro jahr
ich weiß nicht 20.000 25.000 wirklich
und wie lange brauchst du für ein schaf
und kommt darauf an es gibt so viele
verschiedene arten irgendwo zwischen
einer und viereinhalb minuten dann
versuche ich auch eins in einer minute
der start mit briefen sowie
schatzmeister in der decke hängen
bleiben ist ziemlich gefährlich aus
beim japaner plötzlich keine angst kann
ich vielleicht als show aber noch ein
paar striche kommen so richtig in form
das ist ja groß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am morgen
ja
du hast gerade zwei dollar 75 das
schädel eines schafs verdient rund 2000
schafe warten noch produziert
lammfleisch und volants lieferten firmen
rohstoffe für möbel und kleidung
herstellen
das leben hier war ich denke es ist
ziemlich anstrengend es ist sehr
anstrengend aber es lohnt sich die tiere
die natur das ist fantastisch ich werde
nie ein millionär sein
es ist kein tolles geschäft aber ein
toller lebensstil wenn er hier auf
einiges verzichten
ich habe hart erarbeitet
[Musik]
in vierter generation betrieb mit
charlie der hof zur form
während diese hektar land dafür
schnappte schwanken der fleisch und
wolle besser machen vor allem die
trockenperioden johnny cash war
[Musik]
du hast das zelt um es zu filtern
ein arbeiter dort drüben macht das
gerade sie bekommen dieses kraftfutter
mit getrocknetem gras proteinen ein kilo
pro tag und tier
weil es kein gras mehr gibt und du sagst
es schon zwei der klimawandel die
trockenheit ist ein grundsätzliches
problem für uns aber der klimawandel
wird es noch verschärft das ist so du
musst also nach alternativen suchen
ich möchte windturbinen auf meinem land
aufstellen
seit ich durch den stromverkauf ein
zusatzeinkommen
das wäre nicht vom wetter abhängig wie
die schafzucht nur vom wind dieser
gegend gibt es viel wind warum hast du
noch keine winter wien wollten sie
eigentlich schon vor zehn jahren
aufstellen
das wirtschaftliche umfeld in australien
ist schlecht für windenergie die
politische lage ist unklar
die kohleindustrie viel macht und eine
große lobby australien hat viel kohle
die industrie glaubt man kann nicht
immer einfach kohleverbrennung ich habe
das gefühl die firmen und deren chefs
haben den verhängnisvollen glauben sie
könnten sich aus dem klimawandel
herauskaufen
[Musik]
mit bild von glückliche kontinent runde
erst riss naturparadies australien
sprachkraft einer vor der größten
umweltverschmutzer weltweit
[Musik]
weiter geht's in die blue mountains nach
katongo stunde westlich von sydney
[Musik]
das starthilfe andere destinationen vom
tourismus die gastro märkten natur -
wichtiges kapital für australien
graffiti ururenkel formale bekannte
england der ich vor 170 stunden natur
bewundert und die deka rodwald
verhandelt hat ich lehre schräge aber
sehr sympathische vogel kennen
du siehst aus wie bist du denn unterwegs
menschen bestiegen in diesen kleidern
den mount everest
das ist messi kann wehtun begründer der
evolutionstheorie sich von der schutz
von bedrohten arten
und warum bist du mit dem fahrrad
unterwegs
ich versuche meinen ökologischen
fußabdruck so klein wie möglich zu
halten
anzug
ich will safin passt australier
verschiedene bekannte psycho charles
darwin hätte noch einen leeren china
oder in progress zeigt mir die
glückliche wende wolf falls in dem
märchen von katumba
für short story gegend um 1806 ist im
rahmen von amerika expedition erkundet
bleibt wie alle damals fest dass gott
mensch und natur schäfer hat hier an dem
ort hat aber das waldbild risiko er
wandert die hier und da diese
fantastische aussicht
hier entstanden die ersten kritischen
gedanken die später in der
faszinierenden frage mündeten
was sind wir haben wir vom affen ab oder
wurden wir von gott erschaffen
charles darwin hier seine autobiografie
sein denken fest wer schweben
meine goldene regel lautet schenkel
jenen fakten besonders viel
aufmerksamkeit die seinen überzeugungen
widersprechen
das war seine goldene regel ich denke
das ist das wichtigste dass wir von ihm
lernen können
überleg dir was er da sagt dass es
gewalt selbstverständlich neigen wir
dazu alles zu ignorieren was unseren
überzeugungen widerspricht als
grundhaltung macht das leben absolut
faszinierend denn plötzlich hatte ich
alles zu interessieren
nichts ist sakrosankt du musst alles
hinterfragen das ist wohl das wichtigste
das ich von ihm gelernt habe er hat also
viel verändert du hast auch viel
verändert du hast dein leben verändert
viele von uns hatten schon einmal dunkle
zeit geblieben ich auch ich habe
versucht mir das leben zu nehmen
große sache natürlich kann es danach nie
mehr derselbe hat sich verändert
davor war ich nur an geld und
materiellen erfolg interessiert
ich merkte aber dass mir geld nicht das
geben konnte was ich brauche und
versuchte ein fröhliches optimistisches
leben zu führen nicht mehr nach
materiellem reichtum zu streben
[Musik]
chris hat früh in der kurve als werbe
gemacht es klingt aber hätten
in der natur kommen hier wird's nass und
wir laden alles ab
rucksack runter und neopren anzug
anziehen
ich trage 2
und warum weil ich ein absolutes
weichheit
das ist der erste sprung war das wasser
nicht tief ist musst du rückwärts
springen was rückwärts rückwärts also
ist es sicher nein überhaupt nicht
[Applaus]
ist das schön hier
hier gibt es süßwasser hunger anfang ja
klar
sie können nicht ganz schlimm zwacken
wirklich ganz schlimm zwacken lass dich
nicht erwischen
er versucht gerade jetzt bist du denn er
kann mit den scheren weit nach hinten
greifen versucht die hand so flach wie
möglich zu halten
so kann dich nicht erwischen
wir machen es so ich halte ihn
vorsichtig mit dem stock und du kannst
du sicher in die hand nehmen hat den gut
fest
du tust du nicht wie und jetzt die hand
ganz flach sehr gut
das ist ein australischer süßwasser
robert ein händler
das war knapp
ich sagte schon ergebe der einen
abschiedsgruß es ist beeindruckend mit
was für andere begeistern und
unbeschwertheit für crestor in der natur
begegnet
[Musik]
der kreis ist überzeugt dass man mit
positiver landes in der natur wieder
manche finden nachhaltigen effekt als
wenn man mit moralisieren aufschlags
gewisse macht
[Musik]
beschönigt
ich musste es auch schneller
unter tage hat ein problem
sehr gut gemacht du warst super
rechtlich
das lichtspiel wunderschön
der kreis will mir die familie
vorstellen
er besteht aber darauf mit dem velo 1
vorne
[Musik]
chris und 4 km wieder weg von katongo
ich komme von ihnen gaben verschiedene
familien und eure mutter
ich bin zwar nicht kennen zu lernen
hallo ich bin junkie wie ist es gelaufen
ist unterwegs mit dem fahrrad liegt sein
fahrrad aber du darfst autofahrer oder
wir sind das auto team der familie
[Applaus]
family darin lebt in die ortschaft glenn
beck iris ist der perfekt kompromiss
zwei schritte in ihrem sitzplatz vor
regelrechte walter
[Musik]
wir passen denn natur freak und
pr-berater riese stadt sammer auf der
splitt santa cruz und jackie es kurios
war dass schechter zweiges gefunden was
sich bestens ergänzen will steht es nun
mit dem umweltschutz in australien muss
schwierig sein alle reden nur vom
wirtschaftsboom im land die
umweltverschmutzung ist groß australien
hat einen größeren ökologischen
fußabdruck als die meisten europäischen
länder eigentlich als die meisten länder
der welt bekannten noch vieles
verbessern
ökologisch sind wir ein weniger
glückliches land klimawandel für euch
erwiesen
für mich ja das muss dringend etwas
geschehen
meiner ansicht nach australien hat
bereits ein extremes klima wir haben
zwar nicht die tiefen temperaturen wie
ihr in europas aber wir haben die extrem
hohen temperaturen und heftige stürme
das wird immer schlimmer und
unangenehmer nahrungsmittel werden
teurer
es wird viele andere folgen haben aber
ich denke wir menschen ticken halt so
solange du nicht direkt betroffen ist
oder besonders selbstlos unter nimmst du
nichts gegen den klimawandel
[Musik]
das ziel ist man sie interesse für natur
zu begeistern und nicht wie andere kind
stunden vor dem computer zu verbringen
[Musik]
ich dort im morgendlichen ritual wie sie
und schnell merken dass prinz oliver i
morgen haben sie werden die aus der hand
setz dich hierher wir müssen alle ruhig
sei dann kommen sie grund hat was ganz
ruhig sein
er geht wieder eine sorge kommt zurück
du bist geduldig und ja ich bin halt
einen vogel flüsterer vogel flüsternd
hommage liste
wie fühlt sich das an sven großartig
ich versuche jeden tag zu beginnen
die idee dahinter wenn sie mit einem
positiven gefühl in den tag startet
kommt alles gut das bild würde den große
charles darwin voller china urenkel vor
dem schweizer journalist zeigt wie wenig
das projekt klick in der natur zu finden
[Musik]
ihr nächstes folgt warum ist mit die
jetzt besser nicht verwarnt wird
[Musik]
in zürich paris und schwarz australierin
unter wasser so fordert sich 50 jahre
gemeinsam durchs leben
und ein wissenschaftler nicht mehr im
regenwald auf schwindelerregende höhe
mit
[Musik]
sofort war zum glück 12 380 kilometer
australien
[Musik]
12 1378 km australien mit globetrotter
dem spezialist für massgeschneiderte die
reisewelt mit globetrotter punkte